[Musica]
tra tutte le opere dell'uomo quelle che
amo di più sono i ponti
costruiti dove c'è un ostacolo da
superare
la necessità di attraversare il bisogno
di unire
mia mamma è morta il 5 febbraio del 2021
dopo 7 anni di Alzheimer 7 anni che ho
dedicato totalmente a lei
un periodo
molto difficile duro della mia vita
pieno di sacrifici di rinuncia ma anche
un periodo molto bello
bello perché
in qualche modo L'amore ha saputo
sconfiggere la malattia e perché ho
avuto la fortuna
Il privilegio di poter conoscere mia
mamma in una maniera diversa in una
maniera più profonda
e potendolo a conoscere in una maniera
più profonda
l'ho potuta amare in una maniera più
profonda
parlare di Alzheimer oggi è importante
ed è importante che farlo non siano
soltanto i dottori ma anche chi sta con
il malato nella quotidianità
nell'intimità la figura del caregiver
caregiver
è una parola che esprime un concetto
bellissimo non
Chi dà la cura
Ma chi dà il proprio aver cura di una
persona
L'Alzheimer è una malattia che oggi non
ha Cure provate certe Che la sappiano
fermare rallentare o addirittura
far regredire
e quindi come può l'amore sconfigge la
malattia Se la fine dell'alzheimer è in
qualche modo solo la morte come può
l'amore sconfigge la malattia la
sconfigge non nel senso che la elimina
Ma nel senso che la rende umana ne
toglie i lati negativi anche se a volte
solo per piccoli istanti
trova delle soluzioni a dove ci sono dei
problemi crea un ponte
là dove c'è il bisogno attraversare dove
c'è un ostacolo da superare
e la necessità di unire
ma facciamo un passo indietro o forse un
passo avanti ho 42 anni mi chiamo Pietro
e sono un artista non lo sono sempre
stato anzi
non avevo alcun interesse verso l'arte
tutto questo Fino all'età di 28 anni
fino al mio incontro decisivo con lei
con l'arte
un incontro tanto potente quanto
inaspettato
avvenne a Londra la Tate Modern questo
museo immenso che si trova lungo le rive
del Tamigi
e a dire il vero nemmeno ci sono andato
per un interesse particolare sono quelle
cose che da turista in una città si
fanno
ed avvenne questo incontro davanti alle
opere davanti ai quadri di Mark rothko
davanti a queste tele immense
riempite completamente di pochi colori
uno due A volte sembra un 3
davanti a questi quadri dalla
costruzione apparentemente semplice
Rimasi emozionato scioccato e in qualche
modo anche annichilito
c'è in questi quadri c'è in queste opere
una verità una potenza
che non avevo mai visto che non
conoscevo
e in quel momento davanti
a quei quadri in quella sala di quel
museo decidi che questo era quello che
io volevo fare nella mia vita ovviamente
avrei dovuto trovare la mia strada il
mio modo
per cercare di esprimere quella potenza
con la verità
e quindi incomincio con i miei tentativi
ad ogni tentativo
corrisponde un'ambizione di qualcosa che
si vuol fare ed ogni ambizione
corrisponde un fallimento se il
fallimento è in qualche modo normale nei
tentativi e nella vita normale Per
l'artista al fallimento
lo è moltiplicato per 100 volte
Perché quando si arriva ad un risultato
non si è mai soddisfatti quando
si arriva ad un risultato non è proprio
quel risultato che volevi
e anche quando è quello che volevi vuoi
sempre andare oltre
in questo periodo
l'arte entra prepotentemente nella mia
vita
ma continuo la mia vita normale
avevo un lavoro due lavori lavori
normalissimi per quanto possa essere
normale fare il dj in uno strip club in
un locale di lap dance
guadagnavo bene e spendevo bene perché
al centro della mia vita c'era solo me
stesso
quindi guadagnare spendere divertirsi
una bella macchina
alcuni vizi una vita Tutto sommato
normale
tutto questo fino a quando la malattia
è entrata nella vita di mia mamma
e qua
ho dovuto fare una scelta
una scelta che poi
ho ribadito tutti i giorni di questi
sette anni
A volte penso che il contrario di amore
non sia odio
sia egoismo e
ho dovuto mettere da parte il mio
egoismo quel pensare solo a me stesso e
i miei divertimenti e i miei vizi
perché mia mamma aveva bisogno aveva
bisogno di me e l'ho capito Nella prima
fase di questa malattia la fase che
probabilmente per lei è stata quella più
difficile
quando capiva che qualcosa le stava
succedendo Ma non capiva esattamente
cosa e ed era preoccupata smarrita la
terra le mancava sotto i piedi
l'equilibrio della vita normale
e per fortuna la mia vicinanza le ha
dato serenità una serenità che ha saputo
portare avanti col progredire della
malattia
Ovviamente la malattia progredendo ti
toglie i ricordi prima quelli più vicini
poi quelli più lontani poi ti toglie la
capacità di badare a te stesso la
capacità di essere indipendente
e poi ti toglie la capacità di camminare
la capacità di rispondere e capire
quelli che sono gli impulsi del corpo e
la capacità di comunicare
mia mamma a un certo punto non era più
in grado di parlare
ma passava delle ore a giocare con le
sue dita
E allora io le davo la mia mano e al
posto delle sue dita era le mie dita con
cui giocava
lei non poteva più parlare ma la
comunicazione c'era
e c'è questa memoria
emotiva questa memoria affettiva
che è più lenta delle altre a scomparire
lei non parlava più ma cantava perché
le canzoni dei suoi tempi degli anni
50-60 che le ho sempre sentito
canticchiare
io gliele intonavo e lei sapeva andare
avanti al punto che
ho deciso di
reinsegnargliele e a un certo punto di
questo testo molto semplice di questo
ritornello gli avevo reinsegnato che io
ero il suo Pietro ed ero il suo amore
immenso e lei era serena e canticchiava
questa cosa magari non capiva il
significato potevo essere suo padre
potevo essere suo figlio ma capiva che
c'era questo amore c'era questo contatto
di energia
ed è arrivata Serena Serena all'ultimo
giorno Questa è stata la cosa più
importante per me
quel giorno
ho capito che finalmente
era diventato qualcuno
in maniera compiuta completa Forse per
la prima volta nella mia vita prima
volevo essere un artista ma ero
lontanissimo ad esserlo coi miei
tentativi i miei fallimenti
fallimenti sono continuati ma quello è
un altro discorso
fallimenti artistici
per la prima volta ero diventato
qualcuno Ero diventato me stesso
come figlio
e ho realizzato che potevo diventare me
stesso anche come uomo e come artista
nei sette anni che sono stato con mia
mamma ho lasciato prima un lavoro poi
l'altro ho cambiato tenore di vita e ho
lasciato anche quella che era la mia
carriera artistica
però non ho mai smesso di pensare
all'arte
ed era ed è l'unica cosa che in un certo
senso in un certo modo io voglio fare
e quindi sono ripartito subito
la mia ripartenza artistica
ha avuto come elemento centrale
la natura la natura incontaminata ed in
particolare l'acqua perché l'acqua
perché l'acqua
è quella l'elemento naturale della vita
dell'energia è il primo elemento
filosofico il primo filosofo dell'antica
Grecia Talete diceva Tutto nasce
dall'acqua
E poi perché l'acqua è bellissima vi
siete mai fermati a guardare il mare
quella immensità quel senso di pace ma
anche
il timore che in qualche modo sa
incutere il mare
Io sono andato a cercare l'acqua
laddove nasce in alta montagna laddove
ci sono i ghiacciai nevai dove il
ghiaccio la neve si sciolgono
entrano nelle falde acquifere ed escono
dalle sorgenti dove ancora non c'è
l'intervento dell'uomo a incanalare i
torrenti fiumi ma è l'acqua stessa che
con la sua caparbietà
scava il proprio percorso e crea delle
forme fantastiche sembra che per un
attimo sia velocissima poi diventa d'un
tratto lenta e poi riparte queste gocce
d'acqua formate da miliardi di molecole
che durano il tempo di un battito di
ciglia entrano nel torrente si
disperdono in migliaia di altre gocce
d'acqua
se poi dalla montagna scendiamo seguendo
il fiume
e andiamo verso i paesi le città
troviamo ancora loro i ponti
e attraversando un ponte d'inverno in
una giornata di neve
ho pensato
a tutti i ponti che mettiaforicamente
avevo attraversato nella mia vita quello
lungo sette anni mano nella mano con mia
mamma ma anche alcuni ponti di pochi
passi pochi secondi Il tempo di una
decisione di una scelta o di un
intuizione
a volte
davanti a dei problemi che ci sembrano
insormontabili ci sentiamo perduti
ma ci dimentichiamo che da sempre l'uomo
costruisce ponti e da sempre gli
attraversa
sull'altra sponda
ci sono le nostre speranze Le nostre
paure il nostro destino a volte
attraversare ponti è necessario perché
rimanere da questa parte
significa in qualche modo
vivere a metà non affrontare la nostra
vita
altre volte invece Attraversiamo i ponti
per andare incontro a qualcuno qualcuno
che mare ha bisogno del nostro aiuto
Io sono un artista Oggi sì lo so Non
voglio più essere Loro sono
e
fare arte
a volte penso sia l'unica cosa sensata
che possa fare
attraversare Ponti una pratica umana
io l'ho fatta diventare anche una
pratica artistica
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie Pietro per questa bellissima
condivisione
c'hai fatto camminare con te su questi
conti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Grazie davvero Pietro grazie alla sala
così calorosa
il tuo Talk
ci emoziona si è sentito e tra le tante
cose che hai raccontato
colpisce questo appello a parlare di più
di Alzheimer non soltanto nelle sedi
dedicate alla cura non soltanto da
esperti con questa esperienza di vita
che hai vissuto che idea ti sei fatto
delle possibilità che abbiamo di
parlarne di più come possiamo fare anche
impegnarsi a parlare di più certo
essenzialmente quando arrivano a cosa
del genere in casa in famiglia si è
totalmente impreparati
impreparati anche da un punto di vista
pratico non solo emotivo e esistono in
realtà tantissime forme di supporto di
sostegno anche semplicemente Leggi Sul
lavoro che io però non conoscevo e
quindi
si perdono più soldi si perde si fa più
fatica di quella che
che con
utilizzando questi servizi si potrebbe
fare e Purtroppo esiste poca connessione
tra il mondo medico ma i dottori
bravissimi e poi il mondo
[Musica]
amministrativo delle varie sedi
patronati ASL servizi sociali servizi
anche di volontariato e questa rete
andrebbe in qualche modo
resa più più pubblica e più accessibile
per chi si trova smarrito in una
situazione completamente nuova che è già
emotivamente difficile Credo che anche
le storie come la tua è raccontata sia
un incontro con con questa realtà Cioè
ci si sente meno soli credo che tutti
abbiano vissuto per lo meno di Sponda in
famiglia qualcosa di questo tipo e
quindi ci hai fatto sentire Meno soli
quindi credo che anche questo sia già un
modo di fare questa azione di
condivisione Ti ringraziamo tantissimo
Grazie a te grazie a voi Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]